man wird beim black friday natürlich
auch so ein bisschen verführt
tatsächlich es gibt totale super
schnäppchen aber es könnte natürlich
auch sein dass sich vielleicht an einen
fake shop gerate worauf muss ich da
jetzt achten also die gefahr besteht
natürlich und das erleben wir der praxis
tatsächlich relativ häufig zumindest was
bei mir ankommt bei mir kommen ja immer
nur die negativ fälle an
da wird ein besonders gutes angebot
erstellt und da wird darauf eingegangen
wird bezahlt aber die ware kommt nicht
und in diesen fällen bitte ganz kurze
fristen setzen drei tage fristen wenn
ich geliefert wird bitte strafanzeige
erstatten das ist punkt eins und dann
sofort das geld natürlich auch
zurückverlangen
man sollte wenn man ein geschäft macht
mit einem mit einem schaut man schon
gucken was gibt denn das impressum her
was steht also im impressum ist das
sauber aufgearbeitet können wir einen
geschäftsführer erkennen dann bitte
schauen wie lange gibt es denn dieses
portal schon ist das angebot was sie
machen ist das stringent passt das
zusammen oder sieht das irgendwie
komisch aus sobald das komisch aussieht
bitte die finger davon lassen
und ganz wichtig bitte die ware die ich
dann bekomme
bitte nicht in betrieb nehmen denn diese
zwei wochen frist von der kita
gesprochen hat diese zwei wochen
umtauschrecht das waren ja kraft
gesetzes hat da kommt es gar nicht auf
die allgemeinen geschäftsbedingungen an
sondern das steht im gesetz
wenn ich über das internet bestellen
kann ich ja zwei wochen widerrufen
die ware kann man angucken darf man
auspacken man darf die anschauen soliden
geschäft aber man darf sie nicht
ausprobieren
das heißt wenn ich jetzt eine wahre
ausprobieren und nehmen wir also in
betrieb und dann erlischt dieses
gesetzliche widerrufsrecht mit der
nutzung wenn ich jetzt der händler sagt
beispielsweise darf das ausprobieren
dann darf ich natürlich später noch
umtauschen aber das gesetzliche
umtauschrecht bezieht sich nur auf das
anschauen und diese zwei wochen
widerrufsfrist wird noch verlängert
durch die mängel frist die zwei jahre
sind das heißt wenn eine ware nach drei
vier wochen kaputt ist er kann ich
trotzdem zurück geben dann ist das nicht
dieses gesetzliche umtauschrecht
rückgaberecht sondern das ist das mangel
recht und dieses mal recht
gewährleistungsansprüche besteht eben
zwei jahre und das besteht auch für
schnäppchen selbst im kleingedruckten
steht ihr könnt das nicht zurückgeben
außerhalb der zwei-wochen-frist das ist
quatsch bei mängeln zwei wochen zurück
zwei jahre kann man das zurückgeben bei
mängeln und bekommt sein geld zurück